thomas qu'étant fédérale de saint louis
qui est donc le jeune homme dont la
merveille est expulsé face au bac avec
moi alors on l'a on le reconnaît pas
comme on
voit là ça peut être mais pour ceux qui
le connaissent ils reconnaissent le le
passé thomas bien sûr qui souhaite
garder l'anonymat comme l'est m ça
devrait être depuis
sa mère doma merci en tout cas des
dommages s'il vous plaît souple mais
leurs problèmes merci
merci thomas d'être là votre mère a été
expulsé est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé dans cette
affaire
alors
27 - ce qui m'a projeté le cd
dégradation des actes de vandalisme on
parle de trappes est né ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que
tu fais des gens c'est vrai quand
j'étais mineure c'est vrai que tu fais
de trois bêtises
donc au nom on habite dans un match
jelen c'est vrai que ça justifie pas
mais
moi très tôt on sera pas avant le match
à la télé cox ma mère avait des
problèmes de santé
et ce n'est pas bon ils seront dénoncés
on et subvenir aux besoins de ma famille
reviennent de manière surtout
bien sûr bien sûr qu'il n'est pas du
tout d'accord je comprends pas comment
une mère pourrait
encore avec thomas vous avec
satisfaction vous en êtes vous lui
auprès de votre maman
qu'est ce que cous de ma mère oui est ce
que vous avez dit quoi vous êtes vous
l'avez dit maman je suis désolé qu'est
ce qu'on vient vous dis
bien sûr bien sûr je suis terriblement
désolé je pensais pas que quelques
bêtises bon des bêtises comme le sms
quand est ce que cette décision thomas
va pas faire que brèves maintenant on
voulait être déblayés vous dire je vais
pas [ __ ] ma merde dans la merde
bien sûr
j'y ai pensé je trouve que c'est
scandaleux
moi je trouve que moi j'ai été puni
pendant
à montreuil le trafic que gekko mais je
suis souple électronique j'écris
vingt mois dont dix de sursis et 10 e en
aménagement avec le prince litronic donc
tu vois pas pourquoi mais redoutée
rationner de mes actes
surtout que moi je disais 'je suis mais
je sens que je vais payer donc
maintenant on sait pas comment on va
sûrement être fixé
franchement
est-ce que si vous saviez que votre mère
aurait pu être expulsé allaient être
expulsés est ce que vous auriez
continuer à attirer ou à faire des
dégradations etc la vérité bien sûr que
non mais bien sûr que non jamais de la
vie je pense que tout enfant qui aime sa
mairie sur pokémon sa famille jean mais
j'en ai origin et en sachant que sa mère
un jour s'ils furent expulsés parce
qu'on sait très bien que c'était bien
qu'ils vont durer voilà c'est pour
manger pour dépendre de sa maison savons
comment mes romans elle était jamais
pour ventes de la tout temps pensé que
ce travail
je me suis moi même pas trois mais bien
sûr que non elle vous en veux tu auras
avoue adéquat avec maman
obama
d'un magic en gros elle avait toujours
prévenu elle m'avait dit que de pare-feu
bitches du goire avait toujours neander
de match et je vous assure que c'est
vrai à chaque fois avant de sortir tout
en prévenant vous dise stop les fait pas
de bêtise reste pas trop dehors des
banques ray pascal aunis thomas
aujourd'hui on est tous très très triste
pour votre maman parce que et on se dit
c'est vrai moi je me mets à tapas je me
dis mais qu'est ce que j'ai été content
a dû dire que j'étais content j'ai mis
ma mère dans la merde aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'elle va faire comment elle va elle
va vivre où vous allez vivre ont
bien sûr jamais à qui ça va revenir fort
moi j'entends sans
le trafic de stupéfiants et noir
toujours existé d année en année de
famille en famille
si on devrait vraiment viré tout le
monde parce que leurs enfants trafic et
un show en sortie de banc
thomas regarde mine de rien regarde
regarde ce que tu nous as dit ok hyper
intéressante a dit un truc tu as dit si
j'avais su que ma mère se serait fait
expulser j'aurais pas dit les jeux
n'auraient pas fait de conneries donc in
the ya plein de gens qui est des gens
qui doivent nous regarder soi qui
doivent se dire c'est quand même la
bonne solution qu'est ce que tu en
penses
mais moi je trouve que c'est pas normal
qu avait reçu les offres de son fils
surtout qu'elle n'était pas au courant
ma mère n'est pas complice de mes cinq
enfants si j'ai fait des actions c'est
moi même temps ils regardent et j'en
paie le prix aujourd'hui et surtout que
après tout ça j'ai quitté le domicile de
m donc je comprends pas vous pouvez
maintenant de le révéler
j'arrive pas à comprendre bien sûr chine
qui bien sûr c'est tout à fait normal
surtout qu'elle a des gros problèmes de
santé comment avoir faire au mali au
gros maintenant est ce qu'ils vont nous
reloger enfin sur tout ce qui vole au
gir 1 m justement quand je peux me
débrouiller je suis jeune je travaille
et maintenant je travaille c'est dans le
bâtiment
[Musique]
ça t'a donné une leçon t'as plus envie
de faire de conneries tu as envie là
travail est d'aider bien sûr ça voilà
bien sûr parce que moi je trouve pas que
voilà on ne peut pas dire oui maintenant
pour me venger je vais rôti bien sûr que
non bon alors maintenant j'ai mûri j'ai
grandi là ses charmes et de leur guide
je vais recommencer sans je suis assez
grand et je trouve que je pense que j'ai
faim c'est le problème quand 100 en
moins soit mais surtout que la demande
est donc maintenant que je paye on était
dans le coma on espère vraiment que ça
va s'arranger pour que maman parce que
si elle était très gentille ça nous fait
mais ça nous fait beaucoup de peine pour
nancy n était pas au courant vraiment et
merci d'avoir été avec nous quand même
la maison basse à lui thomas elle va se
retrouvent à la rue et vous avez vu sa
mère elle n'était pas du tout